after now two full years of being called
conspiracy theorists and murderers for
opposing the stupid face masks
conservatives and normal people
everywhere are being vindicated as even
prominent liberal public health figures
are coming out against mask mandates
cnn's medical expert lyanna wu explains
why it is so important to ditch the mask
mandates as soon as possible
you say we can start removing at least
some coronavirus restrictions now tell
us why
well i agree with colorado with many
other local and state jurisdictions that
are beginning to lift government
mandates and i think this is the key i'm
not saying that we should be stopping
masking but rather that this needs to
shift from a government requirement to
an individual decision the government
can't keep on telling our citizens that
this is a five alarm fire all the time
people are just going to start tuning it
out and not pay attention they'll be
desensitized and so what needs to happen
is we need to end the state of emergency
and preserve the ability of public
health authorities to reinstitute
mandates in the future if we see more
more dangerous variants later now if wu
wants to preserve the credibility of
public health gurus i think she's
probably about 18 to 24 months too late
for that one but did you catch the
reasoning there
she's saying that we need to end the
mask mandates
not to preserve the public health
but to preserve the authority
of the public health officials
she's making not a scientific or a
medical argument but a political one
if the ruling class doesn't lighten up
on the mask soon she fears no one will
listen to them on the masks or anything
else in the future and she's right it is
pure politics as some of us were saying
from day one you know i hate to say i
told you so i'm michael knowles that's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from vinnie durham
who says no matter what happens to jimmy
carter in the next few years he will
always vote democrat that is true jimmy
carter is going to be voting democrat
well into the 2050s the 2080s
probably well into the 21
20s you know and look people have to
plan for the future you've got to plan
for your financial future which is why i
would recommend you check out alto ira
do you have an account with coinbase or
are you thinking of opening one with an
alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and avoid or defer the
taxes
get into investing in crypto and do it
in a tax advantaged retirement account
alto's crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira trade all you want
without the tax headache
you create an account in just a few
minutes and invest with as little as 10
bucks
no set up charges
super easy
get secure trading 24 7 with alto's
integration with coinbase there are 80
plus coins available including bitcoin
ethereum and cardano you want some sushi
swap with your bitcoin no problem alto
has you covered they have
industry-leading security the advanced
encryption standard for wallets and
private keys plus there are multiple
ways to fund your account make a cash
contribution transfer cash from an
existing ira roll over an old 401k it's
really easy open an alto crypto ira
account with as little as 10 bucks just
go to altoira dot com slash michael that
is a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today that is alto
ira.com
michael the masks
are now
and have always been primarily a
political symbol
whatever medical or scientific utility
or lack of utility that they ever had
that was always secondary to the masks
as a political symbol and now the the
liberals who are telling us to get rid
of the mass mandates the very same
liberals who encouraged the mask
mandates for for a very long time they
are making arguments to get rid of them
on political grounds the democrat
governor of new jersey phil murphy just
went on jake tapper's show on cnn and he
said we're going to get rid of the mask
mandates in schools and jake tapper gave
him a layup it was this was such an easy
question
this should have been a slam dunk
he said
what is the
scientific argument for the mask
mandates and for now for getting rid of
them just get just we follow the science
tell me the science governor of new
jersey
and phil murphy falls silent
there's no question that masking in our
schools since the beginning of the
school year has been a very
smart public health step i think we've
had just over 2 600 cases of students
with
covered positive since the beginning of
the school year that's out of 1.4
million kids
uh so it's a pretty
stark piece of evidence i think that
this has absolutely worked but you got
to meet the moment
you try always to not undershoot the
moment and put lives at risk or
overshoot the moment and add more stress
and mental health challenges to the
system and we think this plan of a month
notice uh is gonna get that as right as
we can yeah but have you seen data that
definitively proves that these mask
mandates
uh have worked uh i mean the numbers you
just presented are impressive but are
they different from the numbers in
states where they didn't have mask
mandates yeah again i know jersey jake
the best but i'm i'm highly confident
and i'm sure our health officials uh
will would could say it definitively
there's no question they've worked yeah
jake jake i don't have any numbers in
front of me and i don't know anything
about anything but i'm confident that
they worked so they they worked really
really well and now we're going to do
the opposite policy which was is also
going to work just as well
kudos to jake tapper here for at least
kind of pushing back it was an easy
question so the the new jersey governor
should have had an answer to it but he
doesn't have an answer because he
doesn't have any proof that the mass
mandates in schools did anything
whatsoever
doesn't have any proof at all
it was political
the masks were very useful to the
democrats who wanted to reshape our
culture and our economy and our politics
for the past two years of 15 days to
slow the spread and now they're getting
some diminishing returns on this they're
getting a ton of pushback especially
from parents which is why you're seeing
the mass mandates go away from schools
in particular first and they're saying
okay politically we can't keep this up
anymore lyanna wu has said the same
thing dr fauci has made similar
statements
when dr fatchi has been caught in
contradictions on his views on public
health measures he says well you know we
get this there's a limit to what we can
have people do right so it's political
so it's not scientific okay speaking of
schools beyond covid and the masked
mandates a virginia school board
has just voted to approve
some true radicalism there was a
proposal put forward to this virginia
school board to fly another flag next to
the american flag at all of their
schools that other flag is the blm flag
blm is a marxist organization that says
that the united states is intrinsically
oppressive and unjust and bigoted that
seeks total revolution in the united
states and this virginia school board
just voted to fly the two flags side by
side
the board approves the student's request
to fly the black lives matter flag and
the board will review this matter
annually in alignment with the equity
policy
all right
so
um
i guess if it's clear i could do it in
all those in favor raise hands and then
if we
have lack of clarity
do the roll call is that okay i'm sorry
this shouldn't be that complicated but
okay so all those in favor of the motion
signify by raising your hand and alan i
can see
so it is three against
six in favor
and
um so the flag will continue to fly
so the flag is going to fly okay
we are now going to have the blm flag
fly next to the american flag but the
blm flag opposes the american flag
there's a contradiction here the blm
movement really got off the ground
because people started protesting the
american flag on football fields in a
lot of other places
so these are contradictory symbols
and i bet you if you asked liberals
around america
which flag do you more identify with if
you ask real real
activists leftists and liberals which
flag do you more identify with the blm
flag or the american flag i bet most of
them would tell you the blm flag
beyond blm if you showed a flag the lgbt
the rainbow flag or the new rainbow flag
where there's a bunch of races in it you
know like black is now a sexual
orientation or something that flag or
the american flag which do you identify
more with i would bet that most ardent
leftist and liberal activists would tell
you the rainbow flag
flags are important
words are important i wrote a whole book
about this called speechless controlling
words controlling minds the left
reshapes the culture through
symbols and words in particular words
are just symbols
flags are signs of conquest okay that's
that's why conquering armies carry flags
and standards they're a sign of hegemony
this is what we stand for and so when
the left reshapes all of our symbols
the left is totally reshaping the
country this should not be permitted
we should use our politics to stop this
we should ban the flying of these
radical flags that oppose america next
to the american flag we should ban the
flying of them in our schools and our
public buildings entirely there is a bit
this is what there was a big fight over
the rainbow flag at u.s embassies what
do we stand for if we stand for the red
white and blue truth justice in the
american way you're going to rally a lot
of americans to your cause if we stand
for pride flags flying in kandahar
you're going to have more and more and
more division you're going to have more
and more strife you're going to have an
abolition of the traditional american
nation
that is one of the downsides of living
in our current culture and when there's
so many downsides it's important to get
some upsides which is why i would
recommend you check out get upside down
load the free get upside app right now
and use promo code knowles canon wles
and you will get 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first fill up you will
get 25 cents per gallon cash back on all
your fill ups with the get upside app
and when you use promo code knowles you
will get 50 cents per gallon cashback on
that first fill up people who drive a
lot are making two to three hundred
dollars in cash back per year michael
what's the catch there is no catch there
is no catch there is only cash back how
do you like that it goes straight to
your bank account if you like i think
that's the easiest or you can do it
through paypal or you can get an amazon
gift card or a gift card to other shops
it's super simple right now gas is going
through the roof
try to get a little upside here with the
free get upside app use promo code
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
you get 25 cents per gallon or more cash
back
on your first tank and all those tanks
afterward that is code knowles k-w-l-e-s
speaking of conquest
great news out of the supreme court the
supreme court has just upheld
redistricting in alabama
you know every
s some number of years
varies a little bit by the state but
every so often states will redraw
their congressional maps they redraw
them because congressional
representation is best done is based on
the population so sometimes you add
seats sometimes you take away seats so
in alabama they're redrawing their maps
a little bit
and the way that they've redrawn their
maps
helps republicans republicans get more
seats
so
the
united states supreme court just ruled
to stay a lower court ruling that would
have required the alabama legislature to
add another democrat-leaning
congressional district this is a 5-4
ruling it was the conservatives versus
the liberals and then
john john roberts the chief justice
sided with the liberals
i don't know how i don't know how much
longer we need to have these headlines
john roberts sides with the liberals he
joins the liberals i think he joined the
liberals i think he's on the liberal
side at this point okay
i don't think he's a conservative vote
he's sort of a swing vote but he very
often sides with the liberals but in any
case
this will
keep the current representation in
alabama six republicans one democrat in
the
congressional mix this is a wonderful
thing you will always hear people speak
out against gerrymandering
you'll hear democrats speak out against
you'll have republicans speak out
against it gerrymandering
is fine
it's fine what that means is
you draw
congressional districts based on how to
maintain your political power okay and
it comes from there was a politician
named jerry and he he drew a
congressional district to look like a
salamander i think that's where the word
comes from
but sometimes these districts look kind
of ridiculous they twirl around but
that's how you keep you know say 60
republican 40 democrat so you're always
going to win okay
i think gerrymandering is just fine i
don't know what the alternative is the
alternative to gerrymandering the
alternative to
partisan
drawing of districts is going to be some
allegedly nonpartisan commission outside
of the
electoral accountability which is almost
always going to lean democrat anyway
that's just had these non-partisan
coalitions go and so i don't i don't see
what the alternative is you always hear
about the republican gerrymandering you
never hear about it in new york what
they just did in new york by the way is
as outrageous at least as anything the
republicans have done the new york state
democrats have gerrymandered the map to
give democrats possibly
a net three new seats in the u.s house
of representatives so the new map
draws 22 democrat leaning districts and
only four republican leaning districts
this cuts the number of republican
leaning districts in half but you don't
hear boo about this you don't hear about
the attack on voting rights by new york
you don't hear about that this is uh jim
crow part two in new york you don't hear
about any of this sort of stuff because
it helps the dems and so they they won't
even call it gerrymandering there a lot
of the time
it's the dems do it the republicans do
it this is what happens when people get
power this is a consequence of the
people putting these politicians into
power so be it we got some good news on
this front in tennessee my free state of
tennessee that i live in tennessee
governor bill lee has just approved a
once in a decade redistricting map to
get to split up nashville into multiple
congressional seats and gives
republicans another seat this is awesome
i love it great stuff
under this new map any democrat who's
trying to run in nashville is going to
have a significant uphill challenge
against a republican love that so of the
news of the day we got alabama tennessee
and new york we got crushed in new york
the republicans are doing well in
tennessee and alabama that's politics
baby i'll take it we can take the wins
that we can get all right it's not it's
not exactly a cleanly drawn map but it
will help conservatives now when you
really want to make make sure that
things are clean i would recommend you
check out naturally it's clean inflation
is skyrocketing
inflation is cleaning out your pockets
with bad policy geared against the
middle class that is why it has never
been more important to rethink how we
shop and choose brands that are
effective
safe in it for the long haul and really
reasonably priced that would be our
partner naturally it's clean they can
help naturally it's clean is dedicated
to providing the most effective cleaning
products for your home while reducing
your cost reducing your waste and
reducing other harmful chemicals in your
home their safer chemistry solutions use
nature's powerful plant-based enzymes to
clean areas of your home like the
bathroom the floors and of course the
kitchen so you're not just pushing that
muck around you're using those enzymes
to actually break it down
so how can this help you fight inflation
you might ask well it's it's very simple
not only do they sell ready-to-use
bottles but a lot of them come in
concentrate options so you get lots and
lots of bottles 12 bottles potentially
from just one of the concentrates try
them for yourself right now our
listeners can get their hands on the
natural it's clean daily wire essential
kit
stocked with four great products for
fifteen percent off go to
naturallyitsclean.com michael use promo
code michael to save an additional 15
off your order today check out these
great cleaning solutions naturally it's
clean.com
michael today the reason i bring up all
of this especially in tennessee is
because in this new district being drawn
in tennessee
there is a major battle
the battle for this house seat involves
morgan ortegas she worked for the trump
administration she just got trump's
endorsement for the seat
robbie starbuck who's a fairly
well-known
conservative media figure
and then a number of people who have
actually lived in tennessee for a long
time and
have
been elected in tennessee the former
speaker of the tennessee house of
representatives a few other local
tennessee politicians
the two leading candidates at least as
far as the media are concerned are
robbie and morgan they have not lived
here for a particularly long time i'm
not even sure if they're eligible to to
run as republicans because they haven't
voted in republican primaries but
they're getting a lot of attention and
morgan got the trump endorsement so
morgan was exploring a run for the house
of representatives and now she's just
announced that she's doing it and she's
making the campaign
all about trump
four years ago the borders were secure
the economy was humming
and america's enemies were on the run
morgan ortegas knows she was there
morgan worked with president trump to
not just make america great again at
home
but america strong again in the world
this is because of years four years of
policies that president trump put into
place
that's why she has the complete and
total endorsement of president trump
now sleepy joe and the radical socialist
are trying to destroy it all ortega
serves our country in the navy reserve
and she's seen what biden's weak
policies do to demoralize our troops and
empower our enemies
now the radical socialist big tech and
the liberal media are colluding to open
our borders lock down our country and
try to cancel anyone who disagrees but
morgan ortegas is fighting back you may
presidents officers disinformation
yourself for years by promoting this
she'll fight the radical left to secure
our borders safeguard our elections and
stand up to communist china morgan
ortegas she fought for president trump
she'll fight for tennessee
[Music]
a rule i do not get involved in
primaries especially in this primary i'm
friends with morgan i'm friends with
robbie i have met some of the other
candidates who are running and i think
that the voters of the district should
be able to choose their own
nominee i don't i don't really care they
can they can duke it out amongst
themselves
but i have to bring up this morgan ad
here because it it shows you a huge
dynamic not just in this district but in
the entire midterm elections and that
question is not
that question is not
who's got more political influence
morgan ortegas or robbie starbuck or
someone who's lived in tennessee
that question is
how much influence does trump have
what is trump's effect going to be on
the midterm elections and what is that
going to mean for 2024
in 2022 are candidates going to run away
from trump
are they going to embrace trump if they
do embrace trump what's that going to do
for them
who's going to win in these primaries
if the trump candidate wins in the
primaries who's going to win in the
generals
this is all setting up
2024
morgan is obviously leaning hard on
trump
we'll see which other candidates do that
around the country and we'll see what
that means for 2024. if the trump
influence is weak in 2022 that gives a
huge opening for someone like
a ron desantis and if you're looking at
the governors someone like a ted cruz or
josh hawley if you're looking at the
senators maybe a congressman sometimes
congressman run too
it's going to completely shift the
dynamic now speaking of trump
adam kinzinger speaking of trump and
congress adam kinzinger who is nominally
a republican but all he ever does is
help the democrats as a member of
congress he just went on msnbc and he
says the most important thing
for republicans to be doing right now in
congress the most important thing to do
two years
after the 2020 election
is to speak out against trump
i always wonder you were you and liz
cheney pretty much standing alone
and the hundreds of other republican
congress men and women
do you ever talk to them personally off
the record
and say guys you know you know the truth
you you're you're you're a bright person
you're educated you see what i saw you
you're not dumb do they just look at you
and go well we want to keep our job do
they i mean what happens behind the
scenes i always wonder because you're
sitting next to these people and you're
eating with them and you're dining with
them so what is their explanation to you
personally off the record when you talk
to them
it's a really good question because it
can be any any number of things so if
it's somebody that i know isn't like
crazy right you know a normal person
you'll you'll hear them say well if look
i just have to win my primary because if
it's not me trust me the guy i'm running
against he's really bad i'm like okay
great but you know at some point you
have to stand up some of them it's
hey
you have to quit trying to tell me how
to do my job you'll get that
occasionally if i ask somebody for
instance if they've even tweeted
anything or made a statement at all in
opposition to what donald trump said
have you
have you come out against trump have you
sent tweets no adam shut up stop
bothering me have you
why won't you do it what and i love the
way he phrases the question what do your
republican colleagues say when you talk
to them he doesn't talk to them because
he spends all of his time talking to
democrats like you donnie so he doesn't
talk to them at all
what he does
is
i love the question he says what do they
tell you off the record hey adam you're
a complete snake so what do they tell
you in confidence i want you to tell me
and all the democrats on air he doesn't
really talk to them he talks
to democrats because adam kinzinger and
liz cheney and a number of other
republicans exist not to advance
conservative priorities
they they exist to
to prop up the dominant liberal party
the liberal ruling class their job is to
be the court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism
you remember when some of these people
used to be strong conservative fighters
i
vaguely remember when we had strong
conservative fighters if you want to
preserve wonderful memories in a
beautiful work of art i would strongly
recommend you check out paint your life
if you want to give a meaningful gift
you've got to try paintyourlife.com i
love these guys you will get a
professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at an amazing price it's not even
just one photo you can combine photos of
people or places that you love into one
painting you choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect the
user-friendly platform makes it super
easy to order these custom-made
hand-painted portraits in less than five
minutes it's really fast you can get
your portrait in as little as two weeks
they will work with you every step of
the way i am really picky
when it comes to art i'm really really
picky i was really skeptical of paint
your life when i first thought i said
there's no way you're getting good so i
first ordered one to give to my
stepbrother and then when i saw the
final product i thought oh my gosh this
is beautiful and then i started ordering
them myself i've got one hanging in my
living room they're just they're just
really really beautiful it's an amazing
gift for your loved ones or for yourself
paint yourlife.com there's no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed as a
limited offer right now get 20 off your
painting that's twenty percent off and
free shipping to get this offer text the
word michael to sixty four thousand text
it right now m-i-c-h-a-e-l to sixty-four
thousand paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most terms apply
available at paintyourlife.com
terms again that is michael text it to
64 000.
also
if you have not marked your calendar yet
for this thursday
you should this is the world premiere of
the daily wire's first original film
shut in a tale of redemption and an
intense suspenseful thriller that
delivers riveting action
without missing a beat take a listen to
the trailer
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
the film premieres this thursday
february 10th at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central over at the daily wire youtube
channel make sure you click the link in
the description and turn on the
notification bell so that you do not
miss it after the premiere it will be
available to daily wire members only you
can also join us beforehand for a very
special pre-screening episode of
backstage where we will discuss the
making of the film as well as our fight
to take back the culture from the left
backstage we'll stream right before shut
in at 7 30 eastern 6 30 central the
daily wires youtube channel do not miss
it we'll be right back with a lot more
speaking of anti-trump republicans or
former republicans or former
conservatives or i don't even know what
you want to call them
there's news yesterday
that jonah goldberg and steve hayes
who were
long-time writers for national review
weekly standard they had been fox
contributors then they left fox in a big
huff and they said foxes is very
irresponsible and they're too right-wing
and they've gone crazy and so we're we
don't want to be at an irresponsible
news channel anymore it was announced
that they're at a new news channel
two new news channels i guess jonah
goldberg
is at
cnn
and steve hayes is at nbc
i wasn't going to even mention the story
because there's so much infighting on
the right i don't i think we need to
spend most of our energy going after the
left but this was just so preposterous i
had to bring it up
cnn nbc is bad enough but cnn
these gentlemen left fox
because they said the reporting was
irresponsible but they made a point in
their in their
uh exit note that they published for
everyone they said we we won't be
occupying the permanent anti-fox seats
at sea and nanowrimo's nbc
cable news in general is a big part of
the problem
and then one of them goes to nbc and the
other one goes to cnn
so they did exactly what they said they
wouldn't do they say fox is
irresponsible and what do they do they
go to journalistic outlets that are much
much
less responsible much much more reckless
much much
less honest
than the one that they left
i'm not even saying that it's
necessarily bad to to go and work at
those places
if you're going to stand firm for
conservative principles and the
conservative movement and conservative
policy priorities i think of rick
santorum rick santorum was at cnn for a
fairly long time until
he refused to become a squish and so
they booted him out but he went on cnn
and he would make the conservative
points and they would tolerate him
briefly and then finally they said no
sorry you're too conservative but
clearly the reason that jonah and steve
hayes have been hired by cnn and msnbc
or nbc broadly is because
they are
making the left talking points about the
republican party about donald trump
about the present state of conservatism
and the republican party
they are there
to attack conservatives
as the
nominal conservatives so that the
liberal audiences can feel like they're
getting a balanced perspective when
they're not they're just getting almost
the same exact talking points from
to people who pretend to be in
opposition to one another
the reason i bring it up again is not to
go after jonah or steve hayes personally
i don't spend a lot of time
thinking about the anti-trump
republicans i don't i don't think their
influence among
the actual conservative movement or the
republican party is all that great and
even if it were i don't you know i don't
really care to focus on all this little
infighting on the right
or among people who used to be on the
right who aren't really that
right wing anymore the reason i bring it
up is to show you
two
lies or mistakes or errors
about the anti-trump movement that
really
burst onto the scene in 2015 and 2016
when trump ran
there were true two big issues
one the first lie was
this is just about trump they said this
is not about conservatism this is not
about policy this is just about trump
trump is a bad man
and so we're just coming out against
trump but we're still conservatives
we're still republicans
it's not it's not trump was elected six
years ago trump hasn't been president
now for over a year
he's gone he's playing golf in
mar-a-lago
and you're still all you people are
talking about is donald trump
adam kinsinger oh he's saying why aren't
you tweeting about trump what are you
talking about trump hasn't even been on
twitter in a year
what trump hasn't been the president in
a year
why are you still you why are you so
this
why are you still working against other
republican candidates why are you still
working against republicans retaking the
house why are you still going on tv and
attacking republicans and conservatives
because it's about more than trump
because trump represented something
which was a knocking away of a bunch of
old stupid platitudes and a bunch of
losing with dignity even though the
people who would propose losing with
dignity didn't generally have a lot of
dignity themselves
and because donald trump wanted to win
and he wanted to shift american policy
on trade and he wanted to shift american
policy on immigration and he wanted his
[ __ ] he wanted to actually do something
and defend
america
and
some people didn't like it they
pretended it was all about donald trump
palling around with porn stars it wasn't
it's about a lot more than trump and
then the second lie this is not a binary
choice you heard this a lot from
anti-trump republicans especially in
2016 but in 2020 too the handful that
remained they said this election is not
a binary choice
yes it is
it is elections in america are binary
choices
you can pick the one guy or the other
guy and if you are a conservative who
does not vote for the conservative
candidate you are giving support to the
liberal candidate and vice versa that is
a binary choice
uh trumpy palled around with porn stars
donald trump he used vulgar language
privately with people and so and
sometimes publicly too i guess and so
i'm going to
give at least my tacit and sometimes
explicit support to a candidate who
wants to kill almost a million babies a
year and take away our civil liberties
and upend the american way of life uh
that that doesn't seem very principled
to me and and then he i guess here is
the proof
right two of the more prominent
anti-trump conservatives who even say
we're not going to be so unprincipled
that we're going to go over and just
take up the anti-conservative
conservative seats at
cnn and and nbc and what do they do they
do exactly that
i'm beginning to think
now stay with me here i'm beginning to
think
that the people
who oppose donald trump for his supposed
lack of principles
might not be all that principled
themselves
i know it sounds shocking it sounds
crazy but i'm
i'm beginning
to think that
don't be like that that's not good you
got you want to stand for something and
you know what you don't want to stand
for
this guy this current president joe
biden you want to talk about
binary choices you want this if you did
not support trump in 2020 you supported
this guy
and
and and so behold
the great
dignified
mature responsible president that you
helped to elect
i don't want to get going because i
don't keep you here too long because you
know all what i'm about to have i've
said and you know what i've done and you
know what we're doing and you know i
know what you're doing hmm yes i as
franklin roosevelt frankly very famously
said
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
and ronald reagan famously said mr
gorbachev tear down
this wall
and i'm sure we will be reciting this
for many years to come joe biden
famously said play it again i don't want
to get going because i don't keep you
here too long because you know all i'm
about to have i've said you know what
i've done and you know what we're doing
and you know i know what you're doing i
don't i don't want to get going because
you know and hear what and what i said
but we all we know all
you know and i and i know and you know
and i know what you're doing
there there actually is
a a weird kind of coherence to this
the the key word or the key phrase here
is you know
and you know and you all know and you
all know and you know all and i know and
you know that i know and i know that you
know
what the you know
signifies
is
biden's confidence that he won't be
called out by the press
if any republican sounded like this you
would have a call to
to
remove him from office for mental
incapacitation
for any republican president and you
actually did get some of these calls
when donald trump said far more coherent
things
when he was in office but the you know
that you know that you know that you
know that i know that you know signifies
that look we're on the same team press
you're not going to call me out
it's okay it's cool we all know what
we're doing because we're on the same
team
one of the crazier
parts of the biden administration is
that he is among the more coherent
democrats in power maybe not in terms of
his syntax and grammar
but in terms of
his
policy
he is
no less coherent than any of the other
ones kathy hokel governor of new york
she took over after they ousted andrew
cuomo kathy hokel is now presiding over
a major spike in crime especially in new
york it's going on around the country
though too
and kathy hoka was called out for this
and they said hold on
governor hochul maybe it's all your
jailbreak policies that are letting all
the criminals out maybe that has
something to do with the crime and she
says absolutely not show me the data
show me the data that my pro-crime
policies are having an effect on crime
she says quote i'm looking
i'm looking for the data that shows me
that bail reform that's the
euphemism for a a a law that
kathy hokel supported that had a wide
sweeping effect on on crime in new york
that bail reform is the reason that
somehow crime is going up she said this
in an interview
with the post journal
i'm focused on what i have control over
right now show me the data show me the
data
so we actually we do have the data
there's new data from the state's office
of court administration shows
that now this covers arrests made from
july 1st 2020 to august 30th 2020 the
first two months of the new law it shows
that the rise in crime is in fact
largely due to repeat offenders being
released back onto the streets after the
arrest because that's what the law
allowed them to do so there you are
we've got some data we've got a lot more
data too but beyond that what do you
mean show me the data you signed a bill
that puts criminals back on the street
and now you're asking me to prove to you
that putting criminals back on the
street is causing crime to go up that's
like saying it's like
show me the data that rainstorms make
the ground wet where's the data okay i
guess we've got the data but it's also
if you've got two brain cells to rub
together in your head you could you can
put two and two together here
of course that's happening
and democrats know this they know that
their pro-crime policies soft on crime
policies have led to more crime that's
what happens and some are trying to be
subtle about it like kathy hokel in new
york and she says well i don't know we
don't have the data it's very
complicated there are a lot of factors
at play and she's trying to hide it pay
no attention to the man behind the
curtain follow try to try to follow
which shell the the
card is under no
no some democrats are a little less
subtle about it cory bush
democrat representative in the u.s
congress
she is still endorsing defund the police
she says quote my colleagues keep
telling us to wait they keep telling us
defunding the police and investing in
communities won't work well
their policies keep ending up with
police murdering black people enough
patronizing listen to the movements that
are telling you how to save lives
how to say we're going to save lives by
letting all the criminals run roughshod
over the communities
we need to what we need to do is stop
policing people we need to invest
in communities
you know the best investment you can
make
in crime ridden communities
absolutely dollar for dollar the best
investment you can make
putting more cops on the street to
arrest the criminals
that is the best investment you can make
this is the sort of thing that only
ideologues and idiots do not understand
maybe i repeat myself
especially in new york new york is a
great example for this because there was
a big movement especially among white
liberals to stop a policy from the
bloomberg era called stop and frisk stop
and frisk was a very pro
pro cop
policy to fight crime
and they said this is this is unfair
because black people are
disproportionately being targeted
by the stop-and-frisk policies which i
guess was true if
if you look at not at proportions of
crime or
criminal neighborhoods but if you just
look at percentage of the population
maybe that's true
but what they didn't tell you was
that not only were the criminals
disproportionately black but the cops
were disproportionately black and not
only were the cops disproportionately
black but the people calling the cops to
arrest the criminals were
disproportionately black because the
neighborhoods were disproportionately
black
so you've got yes there is a
there is a racial element at play i
guess but it's affecting everyone
involved the cops the victims and the
criminals and and the
the neighborhoods broadly
what what the ideologues here do not
understand is that if you want to help
black neighborhoods if you want to help
black victims
then
you need proactive
policies to stop crime this is the this
is the basic thing a government can do
is protect your life
and your and and your
safety and put the criminals in prison
the democrats don't get it this is a
hugely popular message on among every
single demographic basically everywhere
in the country and the democrats
don't get it
according to data collected by the fbi
more police officers were intentionally
killed in the line of duty last year
biden's first year in office by the way
than any year since 1995.
the the fbi's data found that 73
officers were intentionally killed in
2021 uh felonious killings of law
enforcement officers skyrocketed they
increased by more than 58.7 percent in a
single year
uh this is way up 73 law enforcement
officers feloniously killed compared to
only 46 still a pretty high number but
46 in 2020 and 48 in 2019. it's not just
cop killings that are way up
homicides are way up shootings are way
up all sorts of violent crime or way way
up
not going to play well for the democrats
not good for america
very simple for
conservatives to capitalize on this
the way that conservatives are going to
win in the midterms is not by taking
adam kinzinger's advice and
and
tweeting about how much they hate trump
it's not by taking the advice of cnn and
msnbc contributors
and tweeting about how much they hate
trump it's going to be doing very basic
things hey
don't
don't let the criminals loose
hey don't fly radical leftist flags in
the classroom hey
don't force my kid to wear a face
covering that even you people don't
believe it because you're gonna you
stacey abrams for instance is gonna
you're gonna take a photo with all of
our kids and you're gonna make the kids
wear the stupid face covering and you're
not gonna wear one
either very simple stuff
can
can they
do it hey we don't want this radical
takeover of symbols
the takeover of our words with
politically correct language take over
of our flags with the new radicalism we
don't want that this reminds me this is
a slight side point but it's very
important
i have some friends and family members
who are very liberal who use this phrase
and maybe you've heard it too have you
heard this phrase covid positive
say i'm covid positive
oh he's
he's covid are you covid positive
it's a covid
the hell is covid positive
and it just means you have covid
that you've tested positive for and so
you you have cova but you don't say i'm
flew positive oh i'm cold positive yeah
i tested cold positive
yes i tested strep throat i'm strep
throat positive you don't say that you
say i have strep throat i have the flu i
have a cold so why are people saying
i'm covid positive
and why is it only liberals who were
saying
i've never once heard a conservative say
i'm coveted positive
why well we know that language matters
we know that symbols matter we know this
is why the left in particular has spent
a great deal of energy and money and
time trying to remake all the symbols
why they they do it
so that they can make a mild cough sound
like you're about to get full-blown aids
that's why they do it because it sounds
like hiv positive to say he's covered
positive gosh it must be serious he's
got positive
he's got positive in the diagnosis
this is similar to what the democrats do
with global warming
if you are skeptical that the world is
going to end in now what eight years if
you're skeptical that the sun monster is
going to blot out life on earth within
the decade
you are not just called well a normal
person a reasonable person is what you
should be called but you're not just
called a skeptic
of catastrophic global warming
you're not just called
someone who is doubtful about this
you're not
what you're called a climate denier
a climate den is as though
as though you deny the ozone you
disbelieve in the ozone or you
disbelieve in clouds or wind you're a
denier why do they call you a climate
denier
it's not a scientific term it's a term
to lump you in with holocaust deniers
well it's this it's the same thing with
with covidpos it's so silly
i
i i laugh when i hear it
but they're using the words in
particular all of these things just like
the whole point of the masks was to make
everyone really really nervous all the
time wow we're in a totally different
world i've never lived in a world where
everyone's wearing masks all the time
this must be dangerous we better suspend
our normal way of life we better suspend
all of our rights god this is dangerous
the left sold us the masks on the
premise that we it'll help us get back
to normal if you all wear the masks
we'll get back to normal there was
always complete bs that was never going
to happen you don't get back to normal
by completely changing the way you
present yourself in public including in
your face where you where you express
what you're thinking what you believe
what's going on your emotions
no of course now it's going to have the
opposite effect
same thing here you're covered positive
no yeah i'm i'm positive that you're a
total lunatic if you use that
phrase speaking of symbols
speaking of symbols there was a
a really hilarious symbol that's been
coming out of the olympics so the
olympics are taking place in china right
now you cannot get me to care about the
olympics you cannot get me to like the
olympics i don't like it i think it's
hippie kumbaya nonsense i don't really
care the only sport i like is curling
but regardless the olympics are
apparently going on there's a really
funny picture of a ski slope or some
kind of slope
right in front of a power plant and it
looks like it's out of the simpsons it
looks like a nuclear power plant and
they said there was an article that came
out they said
the the beijing big air jumps at the
2022 winter olympics look like a
dystopian hellscape
i think that's right that does look like
a dystopian
hellscape you're spoiling a perfectly
good nuclear plant with the stupid
olympics why would you do that why would
you what a blight on that beautiful
i actually don't think it's a nuclear
plant i think it's an old
coal plant or steel mill or something
like that
but this is getting a lot of attention
and the
the only reason i'm mentioning the
olympics is there is an american skier
eileen goo who is competing for china in
the olympics
she was born and raised in san francisco
and she's not competing for america she
had the choice she could compete for
america or china she chose communist
china she said i've decided to compete
for china in the upcoming 2022 winter
olympics this was an incredibly tough
decision for me to make i'm extremely
thankful for us ski and snowboard and
the chinese ski association for having
the vision and belief in me to make my
dreams come true i'm proud of my
heritage and equally proud of my
american upbringing in
in other words thank you america for
raising me and giving me everything that
i have and and being the country that
formed me by
i'm going to go compete for communist
china now
which is fine i hope she has a nice time
in china and i hope she never comes back
that's her she's choosing
to represent that country she's saying
china is my country okay go live in
china don't live here this is this isn't
your country then you've said it's not
me i didn't kick you out you left so you
go stay there
if america is to have a future it needs
to be a real country it's got to have a
real flag
it's got to have real people that are
loyal to the country it's got to have a
common language it's got to have common
beliefs it's got to be it's got to have
common practices we can't have half the
country wearing secular kefia's the
stupid masks half the country having a
completely different one we've got to
agree on things okay we've got to have
shared words have shared symbols have a
real country with real borders if we
don't have that then we don't have a
nation i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
i'm
so sorry
now
[Music]
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from
here rob
owes me money
let me out please
what good is this doing now
i'm scared
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
you